259 so you can start streaming
thank you
i'll just wait
for chief
thanks welcome everybody to the first of
march infrastructure meeting
i'm going to start with apologies and
i have that from councillor abbott
can i please have someone move that
thank you council lewis seconded council
ludlow i'll put that motion all those in
favor
that is kerry
mr chair can i just apologize for an
early departure from the meeting due to
a south southern district health board
meeting i'm going to have to attend at 3
30. no that would be fine thank you
right there is no public forum today
we're going to move on to
the receipt of a major late item
which is the officer's report
to the notice of motion that appears
today
um can i have someone move that please
moved councillor soper seconded
councillor skelt put that motion all
those in favor
all right
okay now we'll go to the minutes of um
the
committee meeting first of february
um
i'll move that we receive these minutes
and the
amendments that are within them can i
have someone second that place
counselor scope thank you
i'm gonna any discussion on those
minutes
uh i'm gonna put that motion all those
in favor
aye against just as a matter of interest
regarding
uh the content of of the minutes with
the
uh alternative three waters group i just
thought i'd update the committee on
how the other cities voted uh
christchurch voted 11-3
favor of joining the alternative
work group
and dunedin just recently last week
voted 8-7
in favor of joining
okay that moves us now on to the notice
of motion
by councillor clark
so what i'm going to do first is we
have the
staff report uh steve can you
please take a seat up there
and i'll get you
i'll get you two
to proceed with
your report
and then we'll have some some questions
uh thank you mr chair uh your worship
and counselors um before i uh
cover the elements in the report i'd
just also like to note an
apology counselor
clark had requested some information
both on the range of options that are
going for consultation had sent it
around two weeks ago and i have
not been able to get that term and i
apologize to councillor clark so i
apologize to you too that information
would have been helpful today
however we will carry on in terms of
the offices report
we've approached this in two parts the
first part is
the part
related to council contacting and
writing to the southern museum and art
gallery board and the second part is
related to the program
in order to meet the 20th of december
2022 deadline of removing the collection
from the current facility
so i'm going to touch on
the elements leading around the
legal element of the lease and
what council can do in terms of writing
to smag
and then when we come to talk to the
program lee
erin and i can talk to those specific
elements
in terms of the implications and risks
of this notice emotion
the first point i'd like to make is that
the options are being consulted on in
the annual plan
which will commence later this month
and
the options
in in the work especially on the new
cultural facility newer that work can't
commence in terms of detailed design or
the procurement of any of the design
team
until council determines and decides a a
final option and that's
planned for later in june this year
that's a key time frame because it means
that we can't really start any further
detailed work
on the final option until you've decided
that will be covered off in the program
a bit further
in terms of the financial implications
of this
we have been modeling
the cost of the options that again will
be consulted in the plan
we haven't
modeled the costs of the notice of
motion
in terms of the location or the fit out
or all of that or any of the consenting
costs
associated with trying to meet that
updated deadline and that's why i've
made that point there that we can't
provide you any financial
update on that aspect
terms of the legal
implications
council is the owner of the land
and we do have a lease with the
southland museum and art gallery board
that lease was last reviewed and signed
up in
september 2010
and that lease goes through until 2043
and that is for the current footprint of
the building
and the support services around the
building
it would be appropriate in our view to
contact smeg to say that the intention
will be through
either of this these options that you
choose through the annual plan to write
to them to say that we will be amending
that lease and likely to be
finishing that lease
with a view to enable the refurbishment
or the redevelopment of a new facility
that so that is an appropriate response
to right to smack on that equally
council have determined that council is
the owner of the building
and
we can equally write to smag on that
basis as well
so it is appropriate for council to
write to smack to set out the intention
of the project obviously we are we have
members around the table but staff also
support the smack board through a
contract of service so they are aware of
this project
in terms of risks
our advice is we can't meet the 20th of
december deadline and leigh's going to
cover off some of those reasons
why critically to where we're working to
a fairly tight time frame on pulling the
options together and having them ready
for completion is set out in their
long-term plan
any
work towards trying to meet the 20th of
december deadline is actually going to
be diverting the core project team
towards managing
that part of a new project which hasn't
been costed or allocated any time or
resource
that will come out of the project team
and so that means that we will be
stopping something else
and so that is a risk to consider when
you take this notice of motion
my only other point tonight here we have
and we are still we have asked our
insurance brokers around the
uh would a move
um trigger any change to the insurance
coverage um we're still awaiting that
advice and so
in the second line in that last
paragraph under risk
would be appropriate to adjust the word
well to may
and that is to
however advice from council's insurance
broker is that any move of the
collection to an alternate facility may
require the facility housing the
collection to be assessed
as a hundred percent
we haven't got that in writing
we thought we would have that by now so
we apologize for not getting that advice
one last point before i pass on to lee
to talk about the program and we do have
a slide to for lee to talk through as
well
and that's the last
last row on page four of the report the
collection cataloging and packing
so we've made the note in here that as
you know the collection is currently at
a state of 76 packed ready for
relocation
so this is a measure of volume not time
so 70 70
76 of that collection is ready to be
relocated however 24 is not
and the work required both in terms of
cataloging and packing
cannot be achieved within the time frame
in order to make the 20th of december
this is time allocated at this stage it
the best it's 12 months to undertake
that cataloging and packing
and so that's why from a collections
packing point of view we can't provide
that advice to you today that we can
meet that deadline
now i'm going to pass over to lee and
he's going to run through
more of the procurement and the
technical elements of the program as
well and we'll line up
what is the current plan of attack for
the relocation of the collection
against the proposed notice of motion
deadline and what we need to do
thanks steve i think there's gonna be a
couple of slides which will pop up on
the screen
they're not hugely easy to read but
you'll get a um you'll get a flavor
for the storage facility there's a a
number of just fixed processes that we
have to go through so whether um whether
we do one on tidsbury
uh whether we do a temporary one we kind
of have to go through very similar uh
processes
first of all like to say that we're
currently tracking
the early works on tidspray so the plan
to date and the work we set out in the
program we've set out we're currently
tracking that uh the whole the team is
working incredibly well
in that space so we're comfortable the
timeline we've set for the tidsbury um
is a good it's a good timeline and all
indications at the early early outset is
that um that will be achieved
if we move down on to
the lower portion of the screen as you
can see there
that is lots of small bars and that's
going to achieve the um date set out in
the counselors motion
what you what's very going to be very
difficult for a lot of you to read that
is to source a sustainable building
we're only going to give ourselves 10
days
then we've got to enter in some sort of
lease agreement that's assuming either
we own the building or we don't own the
building we've also only given ourselves
10 days to do that
we've then got to fit out whatever
building we find and we need to make
sure that uh building works this gets
designed so if we're making any changes
to any building
to make it suitable to house the
collection we're going to have to do
some design work
then we're going to have to go through a
consenting process
now consenting
typically 20 days is what you sort of
plug in there we've had to put in 15
days to make the timeline work so we're
asking the consenting team to
really sort of box beyond their norm
the next is then to procure a contractor
and we all know how difficult that is in
the market these days
we've got to find someone to actually do
the work
and we've given ourselves 30 days to do
that typically 90 days
to 120 days in the market is what you
kind of expect from a normal tender
process
the building fit out in itself so once
we find a contractor we figure out what
we need to do to the building then we
actually need to do the work we've
actually given ourselves 15 days
to achieve that
commission in the building to make sure
that all the alterations and changes
we've made
work and that we can move the collection
into a suitable building again we've
only given ourselves 20 days where we'd
normally look for a lot longer
and then relocation relocate the
collection now steve's mentioned there's
some there's some challenges around that
in our plan we've allowed 120 days to
move the collection and that's a
collection that is already packed and
cataloged
as steve's already mentioned we're not
that state state yet
so we've given ourselves 90 days
um to move that now that would achieve
the date as noted in the counselor's
motion but the reality is
none of those timelines are sustainable
none of those timelines are highly
likely to be achieved
so therefore
if you follow the the logic and the
program it's going to be very very
difficult to achieve
that notice the motion
timeline
the second slide
looks at the bigger picture so
again this is tracking the the main
museum project timeline depending on
what option councillors pick
but
in this one here
what i want to point you point you to is
is in the lower section there's a green
bar that's dashed
what that shows is if we did actually
manage to achieve the counselor's motion
and we did actually manage to
bring forward the demolition period we
would then have a vacant site
that vacant site would be around about
200 to 280 odd days
because the design process
has to happen doesn't matter what option
counselors pick
we have to wait until this the council's
decision has been made
the top bar in the bottom part bar
they both start at the same time because
we need the option from council first
once we have that option we can go
through the processes of design etc etc
so bringing the timeline forward
moving the smite collection forward
doesn't really benefit
the museum um
main timeline project timeline the
actual outcome is about seven days
because the process has to stop when
councillors make the decision
not when smag is out of the building
i accept that you can carry out the
demolition period uh portion sooner
but then you'll be left with a vacant
site for a period of time and that's
probably worth
noting to everybody i'm sorry it's not
super easy to read it's just a very
clumsy thing to try and put a microsoft
project spreadsheet out onto a
powerpoint up onto a screen in front of
you but
hopefully the bars sort of tell a bit of
a tail
okay thanks lee
right before i open the floor up to
questions i'm actually going to
move that we
receive this report that's
recommendation one i'm going to leave
the other
recommendations at this stage so i'll
move that we received this report i have
a second to please counselor munson i'm
going to put the motion all those in
favor
all right against
that report is received right i will now
open up two questions for both steve and
lee
councillor clark
thank you and as you can imagine i've
got quite a few so it's working my way
through them
um
so um
steve
most my questions are directed towards
you so you you say that
by june we should have an option
available after public consultation
certainly the discussions that we've had
around the table in the last 12 months
has led me and other councils to
consider that
we've already decided on tisbury for the
storage facility we had other options
and that we've decided on a demolition
plus a new
facility as to go forward so if you're
saying to us that in march
we will go to public consultation there
are four potential scenarios that we
could put in front of the public which i
might add the
tim walker report also canvassed
and that was strengthen the museum
and do nothing else
strengthen the museum and future proof
it
build a new museum where the current
museum is currently at
and finally
build a new museum but not at queen's
park
now
i'll put it to you that we've considered
the latter one of those which is to look
at
potentially moving
the museum elsewhere that could be to
another building or to a new build and
that's been discarded
so the other three options which are
three strengthen re-strengthen the
future proof and build a new one where
the perimeters all require
the collection to be out of the building
no doubting that so you're nodding so
that's helpful
because that's the core of
what i want to throw up is the issue of
a sequential versus a parallel process
sequential is you have to move
the collection
before you can start demolition and do
the new one you can't
my view is that you should run parallel
places so i'm pleased that you're
nodding on that
you say in in the submission also that
we need to have at least i think we
quoted
two years i know sorry 12 months
to finish
cataloging the collection and to parcel
it up
so
question for your guess is if we have a
serious earthquake tomorrow
or we have a fire in the building given
that the roof is not fire retardant so
that's an insurance issue in its own
right
um
and we can't repair that damage quickly
i guess staff or swag or a combination
of both would have to move that
collection
as a matter of urgency
right nodding that's that's great to see
that so what i'm saying is you can't
actually move it within the time frames
that have asked the key that's stopping
that is the desire to catalogue it
now i don't believe that you need to
catalogue it before you know sorry
counselor clark this is question time
okay all right i'll rephrase it
why do you need to catalogue it before
you mute it
if i might go back to your first
question counsellor which is around the
long term plan and the deliberations and
council's
decision um
yeah you are right there have been a
numerous number of reports on this
facility
you may recall back at the long term
plan deliberations council
decided to they had
a couple of options to
test and they agreed
and allocated funding of 39.9 million
dollars to a 52.5 million dollar project
and you agreed to provide that
what you also asked though is that we
commissioned the museum governance group
to go away and review whether or not
that was the best investment and because
that that was basically focused on a
refurbishment of the existing facility
you ask the museum governance group
to
review that decision and to test whether
or not
with a vision and critical success
factors established whether that was the
best value for money for the community
and whether or not there was an
alternative option that could be
found
and so your the last six months that
museum governance group has worked and
i've tested both the location they've
tested storage they've tested
the refurbishment option and they've
identified a couple of other options
which will be out for consultation now
this is
this process is implementing council's
decision from last year
and so what we're doing is bringing back
what council asked officers to do
which is to bring advice on what is the
best option for the museum going
forwards that's committed to the time
frame set out in the long term plan and
that will pose to you
the impact of the budget and
what that option might be
now that's why we say we can't start
the design on that part of it
until council makes that next decision
on what is the best option and at this
point council hasn't decided that
in terms of the cataloging
i and i'll throw to wayne and wayne if
you can grab a microphone please
it's
if we
put things in boxes simply
um we have to know what's in that box
because we have to then make sure
wherever we put it that it is stored
appropriately for the content in that
box and part of the cataloging is
finding out what is what we have
and the nature of that material and the
storage that is
required if we don't do that and we just
chuck things in boxes and then we move
them
we're just delaying work
and we have to do that again at a later
stage and what we would then have to do
is we'd have to then find out where
those boxes are to then put them into a
long-term facility so that is
essentially a double handling
so i might pass to wayne around
more of the technical requirements of
that cataloging process thanks steve so
as part of the agreement which the
museum trust board reached
two years ago was a process for the
cataloging which has been worked through
all the way which is the
cataloging and also the photographing of
the collection so we actually know
what's in there there's over 3.5 million
objects sitting in the southland museum
and art gallery collection so
they have been assembled since 1869
so we have quite a good collection
that's available to us
if we were to simply uplift the
collection as it is at the moment
and relocate that collection somewhere
else then we're actually probably going
to put our work behind by at least
another 12 months
and one of the struggles that we do have
within that 12 months is that firstly
the museum
ministry for culture and heritage will
require from us a list of objects which
are deemed as being objects of national
importance
so
we may not be able to find those or even
itemize those as part of that process if
we've just simply rushed them out the
door
so a follow-up question to that chair
so
it seems to me when i look at the data
you've got that the major area that's
yet to be catalogued is the
maori collection
so i'd like to know why you haven't
commenced that four years down the track
wayne
thank you councillor the toka takamaori
collection is quite a specialized
collection so
the work on that collection has been
begun a number of years ago
in terms of the cataloguing it's the
rehousing of that collection which is
the work that we need to to focus on at
the moment so a lot of the what is known
as stage one has been completed which is
cataloging but for me to report to you
that it's ready to be moved we need to
make sure that it's packed and ready to
go so the next part of that process is
actually the rehousing
those numbers are being worked through
at the moment and they'll certainly be
reported to the museum trust board this
week because
there has certainly been some movement
from when we first
spoke with council in terms of numbers
moving on the questions you say stephen
the part on insurance that the insurance
company
may require 100
nbs
um
so the insurance at the moment doesn't
require that does it
no that's correct councillor um
what we're signaling there is there is a
risk that if we do shift the location or
do we if we do shift the collection to a
new location that could trigger
a different discussion with our
insurance broker and that's the advice
we're seeking at the moment is what what
does that risk look like so some
follow-up questions that's me
is the civic theater 100
nbs
i might look to erin to confirm that
number i understand it is
um
sorry counselor no it's not 100
nbs uh most of the buildings sits above
80 percent nbs um there is a few
elements of it that sit between 67 and
80. okay
which is well above the legal limit of
34
um
and
the same for the
scottish hall
is that
rated at 100 or less
um counselor no the the scottish hall
doesn't reach 67 percent it is only just
above the 33 percent that um stops it
from being declared an earthquake chrome
building
so when i looked at the um
issue of the time frames
for commencing the demolition
and after discussion i had with you and
aaron about a week ago
you said that there could be some
potential keyword thing could be some
potential to claw back the overall
project time frame
was that right
i'm not trying to trap anything no no no
i might throw that question to you
um
so yes that's absolutely something that
i said was that there was an amount that
you could potentially claw back
i said it was minimal and i didn't think
that it offset the risks of bringing the
added complexity of
i guess another strand of project into
the broader program um that's the work
that lee has gone through and come down
to that being actually not a matter of a
few months but actually a matter of
probably a couple of weeks
so again
can you give me some indication of
either either v2 of what the cost will
be if the time frames go the other way
what per year will it cost us
if this project goes a year over
schedule or two years over schedule
are you talking about the storage
project or the no i'm talking about the
main museum 65 million dollars for i can
say that's the
core figures that's been banded around
for the current schedule what will
happen if we go a year or two years over
that time frame
i think
i'm happy for if lee's got anything
additional to say but my view on that is
i think none of us have got a crystal
ball at this point in time with the
economy um we're definitely in a trend
where costs are rising significantly at
the moment
um that may decrease once we get four or
five years out um it may continue to
increase at a slower rate um or
depending on what happens in covert and
for that matter world politics i guess
at the moment um it may continue to
escalate i don't think we have any
certainty around that at the moment
just a secondary question on that issue
because aaron you've advised council and
i've been party to that advice
that um that last year building costs
went up 14
um the uh tim walker report which is
sitting here
estimated three years ago that we would
this is before covered in my day
that you would expect a seven percent
increase per annum ongoing
um and economic commentators are saying
for the foreseeable future around about
10
so is it reasonable to assume
from your perspective that the costs
will go up year on year between 7 and 10
i wouldn't want to factor in the figures
but look i think generally you would say
that there is an assumption that costs
will continue to go up unless something
happens
that's sort of particularly out of
kilted that's generally an assumption
that you would make
um what i would counter that with though
and as steve spoke to
is that
uh
yes i understand what you're getting at
in terms of the risk of the collection
not
the collection not being moved in time
and that delaying the project but i
think adding in this additional
quite complex phase of the project of
moving it into a series of different
homes at the moment and then moving it
again later
um that's not a straightforward process
in terms of sort of lee alluded to the
fact that you're going to have to do
some work in terms of fitting out those
buildings even if you don't put
appropriate i guess storage in place and
you're just putting boxes on the floor
you're still going to need to do work
around security things like that to
those buildings that's got every
likelihood of triggering consent
requirements around specified systems um
we haven't fully costed well we haven't
costed this work but i wouldn't expect
it to be in the hundreds of thousands i
would expect it to be in the millions of
dollars to move this into temporary
storage for a period of time
for me that that added complexity in
that added cost actually puts the
broader pro project timeline at a
greater risk than managing the
removal of the collection on a
reasonable time frame which is something
that we can manage through our
stakeholder process in the project
through youtube i can't let that last
um bit of advice go on challenge
ask questions sorry we will be debating
this later sure okay so this is question
time yeah well council okay you
soon to finish or i just i haven't
finished yet okay thank you
um
erin you said that um
there would be unknown costs with
potentially fitting out buildings to
take it to
a temporary situation
can you advise what
arrangements are in the current
pyramid museum for the storage so do we
have a whole lot of shelving or are just
about all of all the collections sitting
on the ground on pallets
um counselor that's probably a technical
question phil wayne yep sure
the collection uh at the moment is
currently sitting on a number of things
from shelves through to pellets ready to
be relocated so um we've certainly been
working through all of those counsellor
and on a final thing probably for wayne
or for aaron
um
is it reasonable for me to assume that
the security we have
around
the
civic theatre
and the scottish hall
and the
fire
compliance in both those buildings
is of equal nature to what we've got in
the museum given that we've got a fire
risk there
um
lee jump in if you've got anything
further to add but that's part of the
due diligence process that we'd have to
do if we were moving the collection into
temporary storage yeah that's part of
the process timeline that you know we
would go to our building and we just
assess to make sure there's
it's fit for purpose yeah but surely if
we've got people
having events in the scottish hall and
we've got events in the civic theater
and it's recently been upgraded for
earthquake prime purposes
surely there's got to be a standard
better than an earthquake prone building
where they're currently stored that has
a major fire risk
you can make those assumptions yes thank
you
that's awesome
thank you
just one one element to add on to
security this is not just security about
people this is security about
our tonga and our collection
and a number of the things that wayne
can talk to you also about pest security
and the current facility
is also another factor we'd need to
consider especially with some of those
old buildings that have been proposed
one in terms of
um the pest management that would need
to be applied and a test
there's a significant period of test
management and
reviewing of that data and material so
you need at least three to four months
of rat traps pest traps
everything from flies to silverfish
within those proposed buildings
before you even moved a single object in
thank you
right
ms cook
so
part of what i was going to ask the
question about has just been answered in
the last remark
but the principal thing that i wanted to
ask is
any of those buildings
climate controlled to the standard
required to store
vulnerable
materials such
as woven flex materials
um fabrics
paper
wood that has been preserved because
it's been rescued from the ground
or all those sorts of things that we
know and are in the collection
particularly in the talc and maori
collection
um
are either of those buildings that have
been specifically mentioned
meeting that standard at this time
highly unlikely councillor uh be part of
the um initial scoping would be to
assess
the hvac systems and and make the
adjustments needed
so whilst they may have adequate fire
systems they may not suit in other areas
so a follow-up to that is are they less
likely to take
are they more likely to take less than
the approximately six or seven months
that it took to get huakatooya's
um
hvac system up to standard before we
could open there it could be very
similar to be fair
thank you just i just want to interrupt
this meeting um miss kudan um council
cracker can we please have live video
look at some important part
of standing orders um for this meeting
so sorry about that but
um
we need live video thank you
thank you
right further questions
counselor scott
thank you so eugen um wayne at the
workshop um i was somewhat passionate
about the time frames along with
councillor clark
and we talked about human resource issue
um and obviously there's a lack of
qualified in that particular area which
i
absolutely accept
given the change with the borders um
just to perhaps find solution if there
was one
has that would there be an opportunity
with now the flow of people that there
may be an opportunity
to assist in that human resource of
looking after the collection one issue
point
um
but it seems to me from the report which
was very thorough today thank you from
the group
um there's not a human resource issue at
all it's more the procurement it's more
around our annual plan it's around time
frames of things sitting into place is
that
it's my understanding so
whilst i hugely support
um
thought of bringing anything forward and
i think we all would is that a fair
assumption from what i've heard today
from one of you it's a it's a very fair
assumption counselor
and just given the vacant site situation
i think was 280 days there is having
been involved in
uh another situation um whilst we can be
blase about a vacant site it actually
has its own it's thought for some of its
own problems to be feared but
particularly over a long period of time
not over a short period of time so much
but there is security there's a whole
raft of things
involved around that so
the report has clarified for me and just
going back to you wayne again around
that human resource
it is obviously with that particular
collection as well
um we need specialized people
very much so even with the borders open
our biggest challenge we have in new
zealand is actually the lack of
professionals in a number of the areas
um working in museums is no longer seen
as the fashionable thing it once was so
we're going to be challenged even
finding those human resources anyway
thank you
thank you councillor scout um further
questions for steve or lee or wayne
councillor clark
just two or three follow-up questions um
steve last year i
asked you what percentage of the
collection you felt was
temperature controlled
or needed to be temperature control like
evelyn has mentioned and at that time
you said five percent has that changed
i think i think you might have said one
or two percent but
yeah look i'll throw to
wayne he's got a greater handle on the
element of climate controlled collection
uh to respond to that collection i can't
give you the exact percentage what i can
uh advise is there are certain elements
within the collection that we do have to
have specialist
uh controls for from spirit collections
to nitrate negatives
areas like that do require quite
specialist uh treatment
two other quick questions chair um
at one stage staff
when they were considering the
storage uh capacity for the
new museum
reviewed a whole lot of commercial
premises around town to see whether that
could have been an option as opposed to
new build can you tell me how many how
many buildings you commercial buildings
you review
18 18. yep thank you
any of those have temperature control
not from recollection to be fair did you
review the qtv building the second floor
it's it's got nearly 800 square meters
worth of capacity and it is temperature
controlled
okay thank you chair
okay for the questions for staff look i
in that case then i have a
question really i'll get steve if you
want to answer this one
has has this council yet formally
decided and publicly announced
whether it is repairing the existing
museum
or building a new museum and
if it is building a new museum has it
formally decided
or publicly announced where that new
build may occur
through you the chair um
no that would be part of the annual plan
consultation which commences later this
month
uh in the second question
sorry uh was about the location if we
did yeah no again that hasn't been
determined okay i guess my question now
is not of um you gentlemen but uh is uh
andrew or is michael morris here
no
andrew the question is going to be
in regards to council's decision-making
process
it's quite obvious from councillor
clark's backup information that
the requirement to
move out the collection is so that the
museum can be dilamid demolished for a
new build
now
obviously we have not as according to
steve has just told us that council has
not
formally decided on any of these options
and it will be coming up in the
consultation period
jumping ahead to making a substantive
decision today does that impact would
that impact on our decision-making
process
you'd have to be careful particularly if
you're going to consult with the
community i suppose that you weren't
perceived to predetermine the issue i
mean i would have thought if you make a
decision today that only makes sense on
the assumption that you are going to
whatever rebuild at the existing site
then it would be hard-pressed to
in fairness say to the community you
hadn't already made that decision
you could always reverse it to be fair
but but it would be an uh a risk
an individual risk i wouldn't say it's
necessary risk for all council but it
would be an individual risk for
councillors who voted in favor of a
proposition that didn't provide for an
alternative down the track
point of order chair
you've just reflected
an inaccurate position with my notice of
motion
i didn't my notification does not say
that we want to remove the collection
for the purpose of doing demolition work
it just says to remove the collection no
i'm sorry i mentioned
your supporting evidence yeah it says
that okay not the nose motion i see the
supporting evidence and that's why i've
asked
um this clarification on process okay
the notice motion is is quite simple in
its form sure but the supporting
evidence is definitely tied to the
notice emotion and you cannot deny that
that's true
i'm not arguing this so
uh do you have a question
um i just want
a
clarification if i may and i'm not sure
to whom i should ask it
but
the collection does not belong
to icc so you can give the smag board
notice to vacate
i'm not sure
legally whether you have the right to
determine where they locate the items
too would you like that question and i i
would like some clarification about that
please because the collection actually
is not the council's collection the
collection is the smart boards
collection
you know so they therefore
i would have thought
should be the people who determine where
the
there's
location
goes
question
who would
like to answer i think um
councillor cook i think there's a couple
of things there
thanks
i am
i think that's a difficult question for
right now because the council might
recall
that
the smag board is a council controlled
organization
and the council instructed me to write
to the smag trust board and it spoke to
its representatives from its
collegial organizations from the two
other districts
with a view to that trust being
repurposed so that the trust board would
become a museum sorry a
collection-centric trust
that has not yet been completed but it
is in the process
as it today
my advice would be that the council
could write to the trust board
and ask for its views on that
it could offer to work with it
but by the time we get further down this
calendar year i would imagine that the
process would have changed
but sorry that the situation would have
changed
thank you thank you okay right further
questions uh council adelaide and
council scott
thanks chair it
it might be a slightly stupid question
but it's wearing these masks folks my
brain up um is there
any reason why we can't progress
the design and process around
construction of the storage facility
bearing in mind that is a
potentially much easier construct to
shorten up time frames
yes
thank you three mr chair
council consulted on storage as part of
the long term plan and as a result we
are currently working
to make sure that that time frame is as
pushed as we can and so we are
undertaking that work at the moment
thanks
councillor scott
to eugene and just further to councillor
londo's point and expediation of the
process
um and i'll possibly ask claire or
whomever to answer is there any
opportunity given the public perception
and the public will and the expectation
of council to move on the museum is
there any process
under urgency that we could
accelerate a process
by making some decisions and i take
counselor
pottinger's point as well
it was it was discussed or asked of
andrew regarding process
but
because i'm not aware is there any
process that we have that we could
expediate
the decision-making process
there is no process by which you could
reduce
because you can't reduce the community
consultation that was the point i was
coming to just under urgency or there's
no there's no vehicle there's
mr chair i'd say that slightly
differently
there's no good reason to
in the sense that we haven't had an
earthquake we haven't had a tsunami
there's no reason to forgo building the
trust and confidence of the community in
our consultation and indeed the
um
the
sincerity of the consultation
uh i think you would lose more than you
would gain
thank you
scott councillor clark you had a
question
um yeah it was just it was more about
the initial lead-up information on
street game is that
there was an agreement between smag and
the city
in 2010 last reviewed
they had an ongoing expectation to
be in the building the course at that
time
the common belief around the council
table was that smag actually owned the
museum
and that was clarified some years ago by
claire to say actually we own the land
and the museum
but again that to me it's just a um
a red herring ring we've got to move
somewhere along the line
and again if we had a disaster tomorrow
we would move we would find places
we would take it to the civic center we
would take it to other places that we do
and it wouldn't take us three months to
do rat testing we take the we take the
most vulnerable part of the collection
which might be one or two percent so
it's secure question you're asking
yeah okay
i'll leave it to my presentation okay so
we're going to wind up the questions
thanks lee steve
and wayne behind the pillar
okay right councillor clark i'm going to
let you have the floor for the
noticed motion thank you just to just to
alert councillors this will be
uh run to standing orders so you get the
opportunity to express your view
um once
uh you may ask questions at any time and
uh councillor clark at the end has a
right of reply
thanks councilman clark
thank you chair um just as a prelim of
entering into this nose emotion i just
want to advise that i want a division
vote at the end
so that
members of the public can see which way
councillors are voting on this on what i
see this critical issue
so
this notice of motion involves an
unresolved but important issue to the
right players
my notice is supported has a supporting
paper attached which i won't go through
word for word
which is wider than what the actual
notice itself does the notice is only
proposing to move
the collection away from the current
site because i see it as a potential
roadblock
and a
potential delay in the future
i've been careful not to enter into
other debates about the long-term plan
or the annual plan
it is of no interest to me to where the
storage facility is its cost or proposed
location
nor is it of any interest to me around
the demolition of the pyramid the
replacement of the new museum that's the
option we go to the scope design
construction and cost of any
future outcome it is purely removing a
potential roadblock
the only issue i present is a perceived
delay
and that's caused by
what i've mentioned before which is a
sequential process as opposed to a
parallel process
for those listening in a sequential
process is one that is contingent on
something else being done so we've got
to build a new storage facility or
identify what outcome we have there and
prepare for the relocation to be moved
and then move the
the
collection before we actually start
demolition
my view is those two projects should not
be linked
they should be parallel to each other so
if we can clear the collection out we
can start and make some tracks on those
i'm reflecting on what ratepayers have
told me and i suspect i've told many of
yes is that they're fed up that the
museum was closed in 2018
and they've seen little or no progress
since then
and that's a position i support
um
and so it's a common perception
unfortunately the council don't have
an image in the community where they get
things done and that was reflected in
the last long-term plan where we had
four or five
projects in the front end of the thing
when we reviewed it three years later
only one of the four was actually done
and so
i'm worried that this museum will not be
closed for seven or eight years it'll be
closed for eight nine or ten years it's
interesting in the feedback that we got
on the long term plan which is the 2021
through 2031
and the submitters said three simple
things
the most important was and it was quoted
in the report long-term report just get
it done
very simple statement we don't want any
more delays
they also said that the building of the
museum and what shape it takes
is less important than the contents or
the individual experience that happens
within within that building
and the final thing they said was hiwaka
tui is not needed
or is not well performed or well
presented
so it's not a very good um substitute
based on the time frames and the
possible delays recently identified our
museum could be closed for 10 years
that's a whole generation of children
that don't have that experience and he
walkatooi does not fill that void for me
there is also a very low level of
confidence that we can deliver
and so that's reflected in projects like
anderson's house the water tower rugby
park now the museum and even the chinese
garden that seemed to take forever to
get to get done
with that historical backdrop i see two
further risks going forward in relation
to the project
that we have in front of us which is the
museum
our inability to commence the demolition
work
of the existing but closed pyramid until
a new storage facility is built and the
collection
currently stored in the pyramid is moved
to the new facility
and it's been suggested as tisbury and i
was interested to hear before
that staff were saying that they are uh
well advanced on looking at um planning
and things for the tisbury site well
hang on a minute we haven't even
consulted on that yet
so you can't pay the lack of
consultation in one breath but then be
gulping down the track to where you want
to be and it's clear to me and i think
that anybody has been involved in the
last 12 months that we are heading
towards tisbury which i don't agree with
but that's the decision
that we're likely to come to and it's
also the decision that we will have a
new museum which i do support
and unless we provide some leadership
today and start the removal of the
collection to temporary storage
facilities
um a new council could come in in
october and we could end up with further
delays again so it's really time to get
started on this project we've talked
about for four years and in fact if you
look back in the history of of the
museum
um
with this is the third attempt we've had
some time ago many years ago we had a
shot at the new museum it was 25 million
we had a second one more recently that
was 45 million
and now we're heading to 75 million you
can see the increased costs and that
those time frames
the second attempt the 45 million dollar
one
fell over
i don't mean physically fell over but it
never got off the ground because ctos
withdrew its funding
and they did that because they said
there were unacceptable delays and i see
this current museum heading down exactly
same track
between 2013 and 2018 smag has had a
series
of uh engineering reports that talk
about the earthquake prone status of the
building and there's the pile there
the museum has also been closed since
2018 that was four years ago when
councils supported the withdrawal of
staff on health and safety grounds
interesting to note that over those four
years
this council has had a team of people
working in that building
sure they sign in every day
if you go new you've got to have a
briefing on health and safety
um you have to wear a flurry jacket and
you have to wear a hard hat
so that is the degree of risk that's
perceived for staff in that building
and my suggestion is wherever we take
the
uh collection it has got to be far safer
for the staff that are currently
finishing off the cataloging
and i've mentioned two buildings but
there are a whole lot more buildings
around that could be used
and even more importantly
the buildings that we take them to are
structurally far more sound than leaving
the collections especially parts of the
maori collection which have been
mentioned by wayne as being of
international signing events in a
building that is earthquake prime at a
very high level
and has a fire risk in its ceiling
and so
i think it's important that we we move
on on that
interesting that
about a year after the museum was closed
we got a tim walker report and it's a
very detailed report
um
it looked at all the options that we
could do it costed out where temporary
storage would be so it's interesting now
for the staff to say they've got no idea
of the cost
and for aaron to say it could run into
the millions well i've read the tim
walker report and it's quite clear about
what the estimated cost would be to
locate
the um
the collection of temporary buildings
both here and as he suggested in
christchurch as well where there were
options
and it didn't run into millions of
dollars
and so it's disappointing that we've
never tabled that report
smag withheld it for the best part of
two or two and a half years it was
leaked to the media and since then it's
just sat on the shelf but we've used it
when it suited us
and that's a very detailed report by a
guy that's uh new zealand renowned for
and probably internationally renowned
for this work in this space that's why
smag
consultant got his consultation in the
first place
and i think it's uh it's a sad
indictment that we're going back
reinventing the wheel there he went
through all the options and cost it all
on
the other issue is the issue of timing
of the of things and it's interesting in
the walker report
that he lists four options
he talks about the strengthening and
reopening of the museum
that's the cheapest and quickest option
with a 12-month time frame being mindful
we got this report in
mid-2019
the second one was to strengthen and
refurbish that doubled the cost but it
future-proofed the museum 24-month
turnaround
rebuild a new museum on the current
pyramid site requiring demolition
and all and
building a new museum on alternative
sites had three options
each one of them had a time frame of 48
months which is four years so that's the
hot the total package
i don't understand why our project now
is kicked out to six years
so all those options bar the off-site
one for the new build require the
collection to be moved
and that's where the sequential stuff
comes in again
if we could move it quicker than our
current time frames we could potentially
bring the
finish date for the museum not the
storage
the finish for the museum
ford 12 months 18 months two years well
i can tell you how much that saves in
dollar terms if you apply seven to ten
percent
of the 65 million dollar
thing it's not rocket scientists in that
period you'll save somewhere between six
and a half and thirteen million dollars
now you tell ratepayers when their rates
go up why we haven't seized that
opportunity
and i've heard a lot of reasons today in
the package that was put up by the staff
and i don't agree with most of it
and so
we've had time to do it and it's time
that we got on and did something
and
and to talk about
needing to consult under the annual plan
we've had workshops recently we've had
presentations by the imagining group
reimagining group i mean it's all led us
down the option of tisbury plus a new
museum on site so let's not go out and
consult again
the community don't care less about
where you put the storage they want a
museum out that they go into they're
never going to go into the storage
facility
and i'll tell you now you'll have heard
it and i've heard it that most people
want that thing sorted we don't need to
consult to do it we've already got the
consultation and all the document we
need
through the um
through the tim walker report the
feedback we got at the long term
planning thing basically said three
things get it done
we wanted at queen's park as part of the
queens park experience
and the awards we run that we we had
recently for the park which is a credit
to them gives you that total experience
and the final thing they said is they
want to maintain the pyramid it doesn't
mean the pyramid roof but just the shape
and so that that's what tim walker put
up
some people have seen that somehow
a really nice design it was up to me i'd
have the storage right next door with a
smaller pyramid as well but it's not up
to me
so i think it's time that we um we got
on the move that we have the potential
for a little bit of unease but the the
whole issue of
um
testing for rats and other types of
insects um in a place like the civic
theater just doesn't cut with me and i
just think we should get on take the
potential to deliver this project
one to two years quicker given that
we've dragged our feets for four years
now at least
um and there is the potential there to
save somewhere between six and a half
and 13 million dollars
and given that we've recently nearly
doubled our commitment to the city block
and so that's been a big hit that our
future generations are going to face
and given that streetscape also took a
hefty increase recently
over what we projected
i think it's long overdue that we don't
add a third additional cost to the right
path because it doesn't affect me i
probably won't be here when this really
truly kicks in but a lot of the
generations that follow us will not
thank us for that increased cost that
we're now piling onto them
and so
as i've said in my
in my notice
i think we are within our rights as the
owner
of the museum to serve notice
on smag
to tell them to remove their things it
doesn't say where it needs to go smag
can consult with us
can consult with the ipag consult with
the friends of the museum consult with
each and every one of the councils but
there is space and reliable space it can
go to we need to say we need that space
and we need it done
the final thing i'll say is in 2020
august 2020 this council got a very
extensive report done invocable city
council level of service research report
it engaged with about 880 people
including ewe and including groups like
the chamber of commerce it was an
extensive report of how well we've done
and what they thought about our future
projects
really interesting 50 of the people
canvas said that the museum was their
highest priority
28 said the 28 said the water tower 23
said the alternative water supply
anderson's house was at 21 and the rest
just trickled away
and you ask yourself which of those top
four have we delivered on
and that we haven't
so my view is the motion should go
forward and we should remove the
collection or ask
tell
not ask smack to remove it they can take
it wherever they like at the end of the
day if there's any cost we will end up
funding it anyway
um and that's our offer to them but we
need the space out so that we can get on
and sort a new museum out because any of
the other alternatives like
re-strengthening
which i initially was in favor of you
you'll record 15 months ago i was in
favor of that because it was the
cheapest and the quickest option
but i now acknowledge that if we want a
museum for the next 40 or 50 years
we need to invest in a new museum
so that's what i have to say
um right counselor clark would you like
to read out your notice emotion and also
move it and then i'll seek a second
sure no summation that icc is the owner
of the pyramid museum legally advised
the smag trust that the museum
collection is to be relocated to
alternative printers premises by no
later than the 20th of december 2022.
thank you
do i have a second div for that
notification
yes uh mr chairman of second that motion
and then settling it
is just the delay
uh hold it um right you've seconded that
motion you don't immediately get to
speak as senator
um
right that seconded
um
you may speak now you can put your hand
up sorry i'm just making sure that we
had the second
yes
yes thank you mr chairman uh
this council and previous council they
tend to like closing down important
facilities that we have there for our
public and our visitors
the water tower was closed down 10 years
ago 2012 anderson house
2014
and now
the museum
come april
uh this year that'll be four years
and it's delay after delay
meeting after meeting workshop after
workshop
and we're getting nowhere
and information i've received
uh obtained regarding the cost of the
museum that is going up between 2 and
2.5 million every year
that
that nothing has
been achieved
so so far
with the
rising costs
um
getting out of hand and construction
cost
up until this stage whatever the cost
was going to be to renew or rebuild the
museum would be up by 10 million at this
stage
um if it's another
four or five years
you could add another eight to 10
million on to that easily like
this is
delay after delay and it's real money
we're dealing with it's not play money
funny money or monopoly money it's rate
payers money so
we just got to get the job done
and that's why i'm securing the motion
put forward by councillor clark
thank you mr german
right so i'm going to open this up for
debate um i see council adelaide
thanks chair
um
ultimately i don't think that there's
anybody that
would object to
um
shortening the time frame
and and in that sense i understand
uh
counselor clark's reason
for a notice of motion
but there are
either flaws or or differences of
opinion and some of the analogies that
that he's used and
um
some of the things he said today which
i'll just i'll go through when we use
the analogy that you know could we move
the collection quickly if there was a
disaster yes of course we could
there hasn't been a disaster
so why place additional risk around the
security of the collection
if you needed to have
a life-saving surgical procedure
you want to have it in a mash unit
or you want to go to a hospital
it depends
on the risk to your life at the time
if it is urgent and it needs to be done
on the spot
then yes you take the mass unit
otherwise you'd go for a hospital
i think everybody understands
absolutely and empathizes with the
public frustration but they don't have
the same information that we have had or
have access to or in some instances just
don't want to accept it
which was certainly the case when we
went through the process of
of shutting down and i don't think
there's anybody and i'm not sure who
here was in the room that night that we
wandered around the museum closing it
farewelling the collection river and
cook yes
but it was a pretty somber night
um
that i still reflect on a lot
and we absolutely want to see that
collection
uh i told quebec
with the people
hawakituya
is not a substitute
it was never intended to be a substitute
it is a stop gap measure
through which we can still have some
historical and artistic interface with
the community
council at the time recognized the scale
of it was was not going to meet the
needs of two organizations ipeg and smag
but
it was something
when we didn't really have any other
options
there was the event in christchurch 12
years ago that changed the landscape
of how everything operates in new
zealand and that's why
there are now several buildings that are
inaccessible
and it's not a peculiar to invercargill
thing either
political interference has actually been
a big result of some of the project
delays right from the beginning and in
some cases the original proposal
that was put forward by smack could have
been handled in a better way for example
it talked simply about a building
rather than about
what was inside it
smag
just to correct some some statements
that were made smack did not withhold
the tim walker report
smag
several members were chomping at the bit
to have it released
um but it wasn't smeg's report
there is
an obligation for council i think to
consult with the public even though we
have gone out at least twice if not
three times before
and have a reasonably good steer
simply because of the amount of money
that's involved
um
we've had challenges around pest issues
during this last year so that's a real
thing we're not you know making that up
for
giggles
um
we had real
challenges finding uh a space that
became hawakitya
and even then it wasn't suitable so work
had to be done to to bring it up to
standard and even then it took longer
than than was needed there were
complications
um
so going through a process i think
personally seeing that the storage
facility advanced as quickly as possible
so
there's a really good first step
to and getting the collection out and
and rehoused
you can instruct smeg to have the uh
collection out by whenever you want
um but smack doesn't have the funds
to store it elsewhere
so ultimately it's going to be up to ycc
to meet that cost
i do agree with
councillor clark's
reflection on the design the tim walker
design
and
my personal opinion is yeah i'd like to
see the storage facility right next door
too
it's it's just
in my mind a lot more convenient but i
also
understood the explanation for around
why
other locations like tisbury were being
looked at
so while i don't
support the notice of motion as it
stands
i do understand and support its intent
to try and bring
the
the project forward to as soon as
possible
council is taking in in the advice that
we've received in the timelines and the
figures that we've been using
a conservative approach
and i think that's that's really wise
because if we went for an optimistic one
and when we miss
that's going to be a challenge
whereas taking the conservative
conservative approach
offers more comfort around actually
being able to deliver what it is we say
we're going to possibly in time frames
that are shorter but if not to those
time frames possibly it costs that maybe
um lesser because we're able to find
additional funds from elsewhere but if
not we're going to need some backups and
again we went through some of that at
the workshop
a week ago
so i don't support the notice of motion
i i do support the intent
thank you
right councillor sober
thanks mr chair
um i'm going to try and not have quite
such a
long speech as others have had on this
and i'm going to try and
address the actual notice of motion and
what it is actually
asking us to do and i'm going to start
my remarks by a preface that says
the community don't care less a phrase
counselor clark used in his presentation
is one of those phrases that sounds the
death knell of democracy
once you start using that phrase or
phrases similar to it you've started
down the slippery slope where personal
opinions overcome consultation overcome
expert advice
and you might as well start doing
everything under urgency because you are
fundamentally saying your community
couldn't care less what you do so let's
do everything under urgency
having said that
i'll get to the actual notice of motion
i have in my professional career
packed
moved stored and then unpacked three
libraries due to new building
developments
i'm very well aware of the logistics the
planning the time frame
and the resources that go into actually
doing a job like that and it's a
professional job
it is not something you do by your
seated by the seat of your pants
or on a sudden demand that you will do
it within
a few months
because
your political masters decide to change
the time frames
and in my case in those moves i was
dealing with 95 catalog materials and
only a small proportion of historical
materials requiring special treatment
and i was mainly dealing in the in the
terms of pests
with the dangers of silver fish
precipitate moving of the collection in
a seat of the pants action
will contribute nothing to the building
of a new museum
it will in my opinion assuredly distract
staff time and resource
from the actual progressing of a newly
developed museum which is what every one
of us around this table want to achieve
and see as their top priority
and it will assuredly put significant
parts of the collection at risk
on those grounds i'm opposed to this
motion and i will be voting against it i
see no sense
in a motion that demands
such short term all thought out action
when there is a plan and a process that
will mean we protect our collection for
now and into the future and we will not
distract
from actually achieving the new
development that we all want
and that we asked a special governance
group
to put vision and thought into giving us
some recommendations towards
thank you
thank you councillor by councillor
edmundson
thanks chia
i'm also going to speak against this
motion and i find it interesting that
the tim walker report has been mentioned
several times in the fact that it was
shelved because as i recall it one of
the reasons that ended up being shelved
was because of a notice of motion
that
led us down the path that we're
currently on
uh that was actually done by councillor
clark and um
councillor biddle at the time
and i i agree the the tim walker report
was a great report and it had lots of
potential but because we chose
um to to go down the notice of motion
route then um we stepped away from that
report and that's one of the reasons why
it stayed on the shelf so i also think
it's a bit misleading to say that this
process has been delayed because i don't
actually think it's been delayed either
it's been
our council decision making and how
we've made these decisions that has led
to the time that has passed taking the
amount of time that it's taken to get to
where we are today i actually think that
what we have now and what we are moving
into
is a really thorough planned approach
to making sure that this museum will
happen um in the way that we would like
it to
i think the risks that were
identified in the report from the
council offices speak for themselves and
as part of the team that was um
part of the process for establishing
hawakituya i can remember very clearly
us coming up with this brilliant idea
and thinking that we would have a
building to move into in a few days and
months and months later we were still
trying to find a building and then we
found a building and we thought yeah
we're going to have our
interim museum in a couple of months and
again i think it was you know a long
process to get
the lease put in place
and then to do the consent process and
then to do the fit out and all of the
things that happened along the way with
doing that
which meant that it was
a long slow process so i have no doubt
in my mind that moving a collection into
some other buildings as a temporary
measure while it might have good intent
um from a practical point of view is is
not going to be as easy as said than
done
as such i think that there is no benefit
whatsoever to
supporting this notice of motion in this
this action
i think that it really
essentially just shows a dismissive and
disrespectful attitude towards our
region's heritage
by being by treating it in such a blase
manner and i think that there are no
gains from supporting this motion
thank you councilman look under
understanding orders and in the
theme of urgency which we're talking
about
um we've had three people speaking
against the motion and um i'm actually
going to
ask for another person who may want to
speak in favor of the motion
because we do have a very busy schedule
today
and that's
so
is there any other elected member who
would like to speak for the motion
uh i see your finger raised do you
worship
are you awake then counselor sober
okay
yes
when we come across a dilemma like this
or differing points of view
uh
it's
i think you
gotta go back in history and reflect on
the past
how did we
get to the stage where it now and what
were the arguments put forward
and the only
big
times um
issue i can
remember
was when we had a snowstorm and i forget
how many cars peter cut up cancel the
kit off and quite said
i think it was 190
cars falling on the roof of the
sports stadium
and
it was
the choice was
get in straight away
don't muck around don't worry about how
it happened
so much but
just
get on with the job
and it in no time at all
we had we had a new stadium
twice as strong as
um
any previous
development along those lines
and
i view that
that same principle and it's not out of
respect disrespect
but that same way of
overcoming a crisis
and it can be followed
so i'm supporting counsellor
or counsellors who
support this motion
right we have
and and i apologize for this but we are
under extreme pressure today with the
pvp meeting and workshops so
yeah
so i'm going to move this along
and um counselor clark you do have the
right reply so i'll give you that thank
you um just a couple of comments on some
of the colleagues comments um and if you
could make it briefly appreciate it yeah
all right
just yeah just a couple of minutes sure
that's all it'll take yep just a
reflection on some of the comments that
have been made
um
uh council run logo referred to uh
the mesh unit well i've been in a mesh
unit but um
it's a side issue but uh the difference
between needing a mesh unit and needing
a hospital well i would certainly not
call the current
permanent stadium a hospital
it's a
it's a
earthquake pro
and it has a significant fire risk in
the ceiling and so uh but i hear what
the others are saying it was interesting
to mention that leslie said that
um democracy was undermined by taking
issues under urgency well the smag group
and and councillor
londo said it wasn't smack that
authorized or sought the report or paid
for it i'm not sure what he said there
um but i'm using from his reflection to
know who who owned that report
because everything i see in here talks
about smack and certainly in the opening
paragraph on the walker reporter does
say that ken
gorby
initially started the review on behalf
of the board of the smag
in 2015 so
that's the starting point for looking at
a new museum and we are now eight years
down the track
it's a bit of a damning indictment on us
because we're no further down the track
than that report there
so that's all i've got to say thank you
okay thank you councillor clark right i
am going to
put the motion and as at the request
of counselor clark
um claire will be taking a note of
who votes yay and nay so i'm going to
put the motion all those in favor
please say i will raise your hand could
we have it by division please yeah well
raise your hand please
okay we have
one two three four five
councillor kit no one on zooms
chad belt skelt arnold
clark
okay
those against please raise their hands
so on zoom we have crackit and coot
and in the chamber we have lush
arnold
no
no amundsen sorry
ludlow
louis
cook
and the cheer
ponger thank you
we've got one missing yeah we've got uh
uh
five nine five we have those names and
they will be in the left yeah
that is defeated that notice emotion
thank you people
i apologize
okay
that's good
yes right that takes us back now to the
last three remaining recommendations
from the staff report can
that is noting
that the committee recognized progress
made on packing the collection via the
museum and heritage services monthly
activity report
three agree that the committee writes
the southam museum an art gallery board
noting the intention to amend the lease
agreement in line with the proposed to
project and
for note that the officers are biased
that endorsing the proposal to vacate
the building by the 20th december 2022
as the number of complexities and
working through that program it could
place the overall delivery
of turnover
by 2027 at risk
so can i have someone move those three
thinking counselor sopa seconded council
lewis i'm going to put that motion all
those in favor
aye
against
that is
those recommendations carrie thank you
that now takes us
to something completely different
disposal of land for a pump station
purposes
sorry mr duo we'll have to vacate at
this point okay
thank you mr chair
um i've got caroline with me
as it relates to reserve land
uh so the report in front of you is in
relation to
um environment southland
uh wanting to
uh take a parcel of uh current lake
hawkins reserve
to extend their pump station
we'll put a new plump station on that
piece of land
and
the activity rightly sits with
environment southland and this is an
opportune time for them to do so
um so if there's any questions
okay just i'll just hold you there i've
got a
punny do you wish to say something
oh no
sorry the hand was up sorry sorry um
right questions
for both carolyn
not a question just a statement
obviously my
wife's a counselor on environment
southland i have an interest i don't
believe i have a conflict
no thanks for declaring that
right questions you've got no conflict
with london
right
that's
that's very good um right we have three
recommendations
that we received the report
and recommends and
the report recommends to council that an
application be made to the minister of
conservation
requesting the portion of the land
required to be
transferred to southern regional council
in brackets environment southland
pursuant to section 52 of the public
works act 19 1981 and that the ce be
given delegated authority to enter into
a memorandum
of agreement pursuant to the public
works act 1981 presented to this meeting
i have someone to move that please
council lewis seconded
councilman armitson i'm going to put the
motion all those in favor
against that is now carrie thank you
thank you
that takes us
on to the activities report
and
for infrastructure erin do you want to
take that
thank you chair um i'll ask mr giblin to
give his update on his portion of the
report and we can do questions for that
i am just conscious that i will need
some time for the infrastructure portion
um following that
right okay
uh three years the chair um heading
behind the corner um look i'm happy to
take any questions i just would like to
make a couple of points
um
and well probably the one primary point
is queen's park retaining a five-star
rating and obviously also celebrating
this month winning at the kiwis choice
awards i just want to pass on
um i guess the staffs congratulations to
the team who make that place work i
think it's great recognition so thank
you happy to take any questions on my
report
right questions for steve anyone
yes
councilman um
i see in the pool report that you had a
band playing
for three afternoons which was well
received and i attended shakespeare in
the park at the start of the
month of february and
at the end of that they had a musician
playing in the chinese garden
and it was lovely because they were on
one side of the pond and we were all
sitting on the other side of the pond
listening
and the comment was made to me then oh
how come this kind of thing doesn't
happen more often and then i saw this
was happening at the pool and i'm
wondering are you able to extend that to
things happening in the park and other
places as well
through you mr chair um
look
it's it's a case of resourcing and and
we have great partnerships with
community groups who run these types of
events
and the pool in particular though we're
also trying to target
our young people
and as you'll see through the numbers of
participations and the facility
our team are having to work incredibly
hard to
achieve participation and confidence in
the services and so they are trying some
new things in order to get people coming
back through the doors and it is under
this covert environment that is proving
harder and harder to do
thank you
no further questions for steve
okay aaron um
councillor clay
just a reflection on the three waters
transition commentary there
um
you'll recall that's sorry for steve i'm
talking about
questions for steve not about the
activity report this is just under his
section of parks pools and oh i think so
then aaron will take over sure thank you
patrick
christian mr
regarding steve the um
the cinder plots and roundabouts in town
is this an appropriate time to
bring up is there any plan
to tidy someone you mean the mowing of
them and the days um well the one by the
airport specifically is a
the due executives
i know exactly what you're talking about
councillor arnold i know all the way
down d street you know like we've got
plans growing that are sort of you know
two feet high in concrete so just is
that a is there any plan there
yes uh through you mr chair uh
councillor arnold
the team are working incredibly hard on
managing within our resources to try and
achieve
the best presentated or presented city
we can
in those road environments we have
traffic management plans
that do
require quite a lot of work and that
sometimes delays that the ability for
our teams to get onto those parts
in the manner that we want but i know
that those particular areas have been
tidied up this week or in the process of
being tied it up this week we have all
identified that they are not up to the
standard we want
yes
uh yeah i just like to comment that
hasn't happened that hasn't happened yet
i mean there was a time when there was
new flowers planted
by annually um by the parks and reserves
department i congratulate you on queen's
park but i just think as far as d street
goes and um the airport roundabout
especially those are the gateways to the
city so
that those are what everybody sees i
think it's extremely important that uh
what do you think uh steve yeah
no i
absolutely agree
our team are managing to the resources
that we've got and you'll note in some
of those roundabouts the transition from
biennial plantings to natives that in a
way is trying to mitigate and manage the
cost escalation that's required for
traffic management plans and all the
healthiest safety requirements so
we are trying to present um those areas
in the best manner we can and we're
doing that within the resources we've
got allocated
okay
thanks for raising that oh well i look
forward to it i look forward to seeing
that and i guess some of those weeds are
around natives
[Laughter]
right okay look that's all for steve
aaron
thank you chair um i'll take most of the
report as read the uh key element that i
just wanted to draw to attention
was the piece of the report around water
conservation
um at the time that this report was put
together which was only early last week
you'll note that we had approximately 15
cumex as the flow in the arity river
in that week we have dropped again due
to due to dry conditions down to about
eight
cumex which means that we're once again
coming under risk of needing to put in
place
water conservation measures for our
community
now we've got plans in place as to how
we would need to do that
communications how we would actually
make sure we're out educating people on
that
we are forecast to continue to have a
dry march
we're obviously continuing to watch the
weather and as long as we get enough
rain to get us through this period
then there may be no need for those
measures but just wanting to make sure
that councillors are aware that it is a
a dry time at the moment and we are
having to keep a very close watching
brief um on our water
so are we asking we're not asking the
public for water restrictions here
not not i guess formalised water
restrictions at this stage
what we have done though is there's been
both radio and facebook communication
out to people just noting the fact that
it is dry weather and some tips around
how you can conserve at this stage we
are simply asking people to take those
measures um but you'll note from the
report if we drop below those those
figures of four qmex then that becomes
more formalized measures under our
resource consent um for water
abstraction
so i'll take it that that trigger point
of four still gives you it's not
suddenly
trying to run out of the building when
it's on fire you're well ahead of the
game you know it's
that that's right we're simply required
to be putting um
to be putting those restriction measures
in place
the next level comes down
which we haven't
reached to my knowledge historically is
that eventually we reach a measure where
our abstraction limit is not to take
more than 20 percent of the total arity
supply um but at this stage that's not
something that anybody um has
experienced here to what they've told me
um
but we are obviously keeping a close
watch on it okay
um any questions regarding
council clark yeah two questions um one
is about the
conservation of water
can you give us some idea of where the
drilling for an alternative water supply
is actually at we've talked about it for
quite a few years and it is a quite a
strategic risk for the city
absolutely um so there has been drilling
that's been underway since last year um
we've now got test boards down which are
essentially abstracting water and we are
monitoring the quality of that water and
having it assessed by um by a
professional firm
um the intention is to come back to
council
next month and report on both the
findings from the volume of water and
the quality of water that's been sourced
from that project
and also i guess uh just to flag a
broader strategic conversation for us to
have or for council to have um around
what we might want the use of that water
to be and how we may actually invest in
that going forward
sure
and the second issue is the three waters
transition commentary that's there
just want to note for the record that um
if we cast our minds back that the dia
on behalf of the government asked us
last year not to consult with our
communities at that stage and gave us an
eight week period
put up our concerns which you quite
rightly reflect
have not been answered
and i find it interesting that last week
cabinet papers were released under the
official information act that show that
three months before we were asked to
consult that a repaired um government
had already made the decision to mandate
three waters
so i guess that's
just want to reflect that's an area of
frustration and i think a lot of
councils around the country feel quite
let down by the process they entered
into the eight week consultation period
in good faith
didn't get any replies only to find out
the decision had already been made
and the opportunity to consult with
their communities went with that as well
thank you
yes that's right no we need to consult
with our communities and and that was
not fair
okay any further questions
no yes your worship just a brief thing
i've often asked if the water tower
is actually functioning as a water tower
uh yes your worship the water tower
continues to be connected to the supply
and is a functioning part of the network
thank you
right the recommendation
is that the report activities report
will be received i'll move that
secondary council ludlow and put the
motion all those in favor all right
yes that is now carried
now we're going to
move to public excluded and um
this is the freeholding of land
you